in the Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild you start your adventure with
nothing but an old shirt and well-worn
trousers but as you progress there are
plenty of armor sets to find that offer
more useful bonuses than just an
increase to your defense whether it's a
boost to your attack or climbing speed
there are a multitude of sets that stand
apart from the rest
that's why we've compiled our picks of
the best armor sets available for more
on where to find the armor we highlight
in this video check out the link in the
description below and if you enjoyed
this video like it and subscribe to our
YouTube channel for more features on
breath of the wild and be sure to watch
our video on how to defeat all of the
game's mini bosses the climbers armor is
the most advantageous set in the game as
each of its individual parts drastically
increase your climbing speed combined
wearing the set with the speed enhancing
elixir of food and you'll be clamoring
to the top of the mountain in no time in
addition if you upgrade each of its
pieces twice the stamina consumed by
your climbing jump decreases
[Music]
the Barbarian Armour set is helpful for
tough combat encounters as each of its
individual parts increase the strength
of your attacks once the armour reaches
its tier to upgrade your charge attack
stamina tolerance increases allowing you
to charge or use the attack longer
depending on the weapon the zora armor
is the best set to equip while swimming
it greatly boosts your swimming speed
and when you upgrade the whole set twice
the stamina consumed by your - stroke is
decreased its helmet also allows you to
perform a spin attack while you're
swimming so you never have to worry
about those pesky water octoroks ever
again though lizalfos on the other hand
come on come on get closer you
the stealth armor is modeled after the
appearance of the classic sheikah clan
outfit worn by Sheik from The Legend of
Zelda Ocarina of Time the stealth boost
provided by its individual components
make it an invaluable armor set to use
when sneaking up on animals and enemies
it's tier to upgrade bonus also grants
you a movement speed bonus at nighttime
when you wear all three pieces in terms
of pure defense you might think that the
soldiers armor is the go-to set while
it's easy to assume this it's actually
the champions tunic that sports the
highest defense it's a pain to acquire
all the dragon shards needed to upgrade
the tunic but it's well worth the
trouble
plus the ability to see enemy HP is an
indispensable perk the ancient armor is
a handy set to wear went up against
Guardians as its parts offer you a
defensive boost against their
devastating laser blasts and when all of
its parts are upgraded twice the set
gives you an added proficiency with
ancient weapons which increases their
overall attack power
[Music]
the Thunder helm is a useful piece of
armor that you should take the time to
seek out it literally makes you immune
to lightning strikes and if you're
standing in water while being shocked
you won't be damaged either and it
doesn't cause you to drop your metal
equipment however if the enemy is
shooting electric arrows you will take
normal arrow damage so you should wear
some kind of armor with the Thunder helm
equipped you'll never have to worry
about thunderstorms or electrical
attacks ever again what are your
favorite armor sets let us know in the
comments below and for more coverage on
the legend of zelda wrath of the wild be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]
you
[Music]